foreign
[Music]
Torres Strait Islander peoples have
occupied the Australian continent for
over 60 000 years and represent the
oldest continuous living cultures in
human history
they have maintained a relationship with
Australia's land Waters and skies since
time immemorial
yet Aboriginal and Torres Strait
Islander peoples are not recognized in
our constitution
[Music]
The Voice is not going to fix one iota
of the problems that we have in in
indigenous affairs
we have black bodies dying at the hands
of the system and we have solutions to
this catastrophe crisis that's been
going on against First Nations people
for far too long uh that this government
and the previous government just are not
interested in implementing
[Music]
thank you
we are one step closer to making history
one step closer to creating a voice
that will make sure the voices of our
people are heard
One Step Closer
to improving lives with the voice that
makes a difference
One Step Closer
to moving Australia forward for everyone
foreign